Aldona my name is Pierre welcome back to
gray it's a pretty normal game where
babies fight with lice and stuff yeah
that's right babies you keep doing what
you doing and I won't do anything bad to
your diet a big shot
oh hello flying scissor keep doing what
you're doing
I'm spanner oh my god
yeah that's good scissor happy for you
brah
no no no no no bro not cool
my mom is freaking me out here she's
[ __ ] creepy I hate girls or anyone
mid-age that's SARS or white and just
scary
alright break [ __ ] what is that the [ __ ]
is this well I think it's for my drill
yeah it's for my drill call cool story
Oh baby
where have you been on my lad a health
pack would still be [ __ ] nice I don't
know if you noticed my health yet we're
pretty [ __ ] come on
well we're double [ __ ] now
yes don't take one step closer and above
your head I don't care if you don't have
any I don't even have a head that's
awkward
I'm sorry proceed oh that's gonna
explode this door is too nice too
ah what in the heavens on earth but I
wanna be wise don't buy the lies don't
you think you could put your skill to a
better use be wise don't panelize don't
rise got what what happened here
I was not it was not an accident he
totally did it on purpose
ya little [ __ ] No ah look at my
health what am I supposed to do there
what shut up I don't want to play with
you anymore
I can't go back now I wanted to go uh
okay what if we go over here oh we go to
a different place dude all right that's
awesome
hey guys what's up but like okay the
fine
you don't want to hang out with me you
could just say it alright I don't know
where we are
that's [ __ ] long let's go to the
other way yeah that's fine I don't I
don't
hey creepy trees I creepy tree that's
nice
she just don't kill me right now I don't
have anything to do it's not a [ __ ]
beer
I forgot what you're supposed to do if
you could encounter off beer
that is totally a beer that I died from
a beer yeah I did that looks a lot like
a freedom monster thing come on
Oh baby baby girl
I just want to rock your world with my
[ __ ] girl uh-huh uh-huh Petey pi16
blocking the door from the other side
let's just scanning somehow I must get
in somehow all right don't worry I'm
genius oh I am a genie huh whoa
barrels smack in town oh boy
all right cool hello Wow I did not go
splat all right I can do it Oh nah
you're too slow hot damn
okay one is not enough to kill them
sorry I'm too focused I know health
packs where where are they how do you
heal seriously
it's insane okay I'm obviously missing
something in here laka I thought this
would be like enough oh there's a door
there well it's the entrance I'm stupid
bam bam
you can't block I can come them name is
that
well [ __ ] Alvin please no can I break
this desk up can I break this foot
it's a [ __ ] foot it's a [ __ ] foot
take a pickup ticka ticka ticka oh I get
in alright you have your foot you're
welcome I said yeah Wow got it okay
let's go to the other one let's go in
here yeah and he's gonna have them oh
this is gonna be impossible
how are in the fruit Graham I supposed
to do this this is stupid I should not
be doing there and now they're gonna
[ __ ] kill me [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off come on it's important do that
without with the health I have right now
I think we should just go for the right
um we went in there alright what's going
on here guys what's that what's that oh
come on fine
see if I care okay I can I'm sorry I was
this game I'll drill your brains out
[ __ ]
come on it's raining blood come on oh
it's a puzzle okay genius pills activate
we have numbers on them
this one says one I guess it's worth
it's not worth giving a go all right I
solve that by pure geniusness not by hmm
anything else just pure genius Ness oh
how nice
look at this room oh it's a doc oh let
me let me open for your bra what the
hell holy pens
I like those more it's locked
can Joe Pena all right doggie don't [ __ ]
with me
hey Nigel shut up guy little [ __ ] oh
hell no what's up with the baby what am
i doing fine I'll go back huh speller ah
shut I don't like this
shut up okay okay okay
what the hell oh the hand yes I got it
what no no no I got the hands please ah
ah ha ha ha ha oh it's gonna be so much
editing
give me your sniffing what what's in the
heavens what why did I die I don't know
uh say take dad get the [ __ ] out a
little bit jumbled up a little lip oh
what the [ __ ]
ah come [ __ ] help
Chara
come at me bro that's right
are you double kill there you go lady
there you go you got your new hand now
now ladies and gentlemen how the [ __ ] on
the drops no cut am I going to kill a
hundred million babies with nothing but
Mellie weapons run baby to baby oh oh oh
sweet baby for baby five [ __ ]
baby what ah my that was MLG as [ __ ]
very when she was sweet
for only a moment before the taste had
nothing in my mouth I'd act a part of
justice but under the gun isn't mental
in it without the ability to reason to
think clearly how could I expect to
reality tell good for you my action
however well intended cannot be viewed
clearly when I am unable to tell a fact
from fiction objective reality
plus everything can be seen from another
player eventually I resurfaced from the
fuel agree I had blacked out
I find myself back at home so we came
home and now my help is back what girl
this is not my home fairly sergeant that
this is not my own what the hell was
that
Oh what are you doing no no bad babies
I [ __ ] I don't have any shut up what do
you want from me oh stop what do you
want shut up the hell
stop be a nice baby for [ __ ] out come
on
shall I Shh you call yourself a baby
you're not even Justin Bieber
you're not even [ __ ] up they have things
in them give me all the [ __ ] alright I
guess I'll [ __ ] shoot you
oh I died fantastic
I'm a genius at this game oh shoot them
Oh Oh baby baby baby alright I got how
I'd kill them now in the next episode we
will actually do it
yeah comparative she enjoyed Jeff
catechol number today and I'll see you
next different so don't whatever army
yeah it presents it great mm do it
through I can do it one rule yes I read
raka nice but what yeah oh yeah what
don't watch more minute sleepy oh yeah